[Musica]
qualche anno fa dopo un'intervista il
cameraman che accompagnava il
giornalista si è fermato a parlare con
me era rimasto stupito dalle cose che
avevo detto perché aveva sempre sentito
tutt'altro su quell'argomento e voleva
dei chiarimenti
così gli ho portato le prove di quello
che avevo detto ti ho mostrato come le
sue convinzioni non avessero un
fondamento scientifico e abbiamo
chiacchierato piacevolmente per una
mezz'ora alla fine lui mi ha detto io ho
capito ma non mi fido ho capito ma non
mi fido ancora oggi sono grata quella
persona per la lezione che mi ha dato
quel giorno ho capito che non avevo
capito niente avevo sbagliato tutto non
so se da loro ho imparato come si fa a
comunicare ma sicuramente ho imparato
come non si fa come mi sono sentita è
stato frustrante
sì molto ma anche sfidante se i fatti
sono qui e sono dimostrati io devo
trovare il modo di comunicarli in
maniera efficace cioè in maniera che
giungano ad aiutare le nostre decisioni
così ho cominciato a studiare volevo
capire meglio
ero curiosa il fatto è che tutti noi
viaggiamo accompagnati dai nostri
preconcetti
ci siamo evoluti così hanno anche una
loro utilità diciamo che i preconcetti
sono delle idee prefabbricate pronte
all'uso che ci portiamo dietro pronte
per essere usate velocemente quando
dobbiamo prendere decisioni rapide però
hanno anche un effetto collaterale
piuttosto serio ci impediscono di
prendere in considerazione nuove
informazioni soprattutto quando queste
sono in contraddizione con le
convinzioni che già abbiamo
ci rendono poco agili ci rendono
difficile cambiare idea
sì perché cambiare idea e doloroso
significa ammettere che ci siamo
sbagliati
la nostra mente è fatta così questo
fenomeno si chiama dissonanza cognitiva
ci fa soffrire e la mente farà di tutto
per evitarlo
dobbiamo saperlo
però questa cosa è seccante abbiamo
bisogno di prendere la decisione giusta
o perlomeno la più giusta da te le
informazioni in nostro possesso
come possiamo fare esistono dei
trucchetti per imbrogliare la mente
rispettando le sue dinamiche ma
contemporaneamente permettendoci di
acquisire nuove informazioni e cambiare
idea se è il caso per esempio un sistema
è quello di concedere dei punti di
vantaggio alla mente adularla sei stata
brava le informazioni che avevi le
convinzioni che avevi erano corrette
accettabile date le informazioni in suo
possesso
ora però ce ne sono di nuove mostrami
quanto sei agile quanto sei svelta
adeguarti cosa e così possiamo
permetterci il lusso di essere
condiscendenti verso noi stessi
a questo punto vi starete chiedendo di
che cosa io stessi parlando quel giorno
cosa mai ci sarà di così spinoso
spaventoso da essere assolutamente
rifiutato beh io parlavo di agricoltura
di cibo di innovazioni legate al sistema
di produzione del cibo di genetica di
biotecnologie non parlerò qui oggi ed ex
è una tazza di tè che ristora per una
manciata di minuti un un respiro di idee
e di stimoli però voglio dirvi che sono
preoccupata perchè vedo come la nostra
società sta affrontando le decisioni
relative alla produzione del cibo
siccome un argomento delicato perché
tocca la nostra pancia tocca le
tradizioni gastronomiche l'ambiente e la
sua tutela il paesaggio la salute è
argomento infarcito di ideologie e
quindi di preconcetti tutti pensiamo di
avere la ricetta giusta per fare
agricoltura in modo sostenibile
ne siamo davvero convinti e quindi
quando arriva un'idea diversa ci
chiudiamo in difesa pronti a
contrattaccare per demolirla il
mainstream è davvero potente
la
narrazione dominante che abbiamo sentito
per anni nelle pubblicità di certi
supermercati per esempio o abbiamo visto
in certe trasmissioni televisive o
abbiamo letto nei racconti e negli
articoli di alcuni opinionisti eccetera
ecco quella narrazione dominante ha dato
forma ai nostri pensieri e quindi oggi
per istinto ci appare buona pulita e
giusta non lo metteremo mai in
discussione
a questo vale per tutti attenzione è un
rischio che corriamo tutti davanti a un
dato verificato che ci mostri che la
nostra posizione ha dei limiti
noi non cambieremo idea troveremo un
motivo diverso per continuare a pensarla
nello stesso modo continuare a fare come
abbiamo sempre fatto e dimostrato ci
sono molti anni di studio e tanti lavori
scientifici che lo provano
siamo fatti così ed è meglio saperlo
anche la democrazia deve farci i conti
d'altra parte veniamo da un periodo
molto istruttivo in questo senso
avrete sentito parlare di info demi a
quella cacofonia di informazioni alla
quale siamo stati sottoposti in questo
ultimo anno il disagio che ci ha
provocato è tale che in alcune
manifestazioni di protesta sono comparse
dei cartelli con scritto basta scienza
il che ovviamente ha un assurdo voglio
dire possiamo prendere posizione contro
una presa di posizione ma la scienza non
prende posizione che senso ha attaccarla
e però è indicativo della frustrazione
della paura che alcuni provano e
comprensibile a volte alcune persone mi
chiedono ma tu come fai a scegliere di
chi fidarti quale giornalista quale
comunicatrice quale divulgatore io
scelgo chi tiene alla propria
reputazione di affidabilità che ogni
mattina verifica quello che dirà perché
la figuraccia di scrivere cose non
verificate
non la vuole fare io scelgo chi non può
permettersi di perdere la propria
reputazione
perché è la cosa più preziosa che ha e
quindi comunica con responsabilità il
tema conduttore di oggi essa con chance
seconda possibilità se incontrassi oggi
quel cameraman cosa gli direi
credo che non mi preoccuperei di
togliergli le sue paure lascerei ho
capito che ci affezioniamo alle nostre
paure
no penso piuttosto che gli mostrerei
quali opportunità ci stiamo perdendo
quali possibilità di produzione di cibo
sostenibile alle quali abbiamo detto di
no
vantaggi perduti sì credo che farei così
perché ho imparato che ciascuno di noi
ha delle paure che vanno rispettate e
delle quali solo noi siamo responsabili
quindi oggi quando devo parlare di temi
complessi di visivi che spaventano
cosa faccio beh penso alla signora paola
una signora che mi segue e che mi ha
scritto dopo aver letto un mio articolo
in cui parlavo di agricultura e
innovazione ambientalismo
quell'ambientalismo che ha perso di
vista la sua missione originale e
rifiuta innovazioni utili anche
all'ambiente
in nome dell'ideologia la signora paola
mi ha scritto ho cominciato a
interessarmi di agricoltura alla tenera
età di 73 anni per amore dei miei nipoti
perché ho capito che gran parte del loro
futuro dipende da questa branca della
scienza e parlando del marketing della
paura quel marketing che sfrutta le
paure dei consumatori mi ha chiesto a
chi giova non voglio più essere un utile
idiota nelle mani di qualcun altro io le
ho risposto che lei non è certo un utile
idiota lei è la prova vivente che la
democrazia è un valore immenso
lei è la prova di quanto prezioso è un
voto elettorale una scelta d'acquisto
una libertà di pensiero
una scelta di condivisione di contenuti
e riflessioni che cosa muove la signora
paola la curiosità che
non ha età e che è forte abbastanza da
spingerci a guardare oltre le nostre
convinzioni
la curiosità è un'alleata preziosa per
prendere per mano le nostre paure
la nostra mente e ricominciare a
camminare
il motore della scoperta del nuovo
questa non è una storia a lieto fine
questa è una storia ancora senza fine
non possiamo vivere senza ideologie e
vero però possiamo continuare a
guardarle in faccia con genuina
curiosità